how long were you in the navy for 21
years did you get a purple heart for
being wounded i did and
what would you tell people when some
other you know you're out you're near
jess white's for whatever reason and you
know
1975 there's
the guys were in vietnam sure some you
know guys there's some corman some
medics some pilots some aviators might
have got purple hearts some some guys
from the sea wolves or something but
there's not a lot of navy guys running
around in 1975 1980 1985 that had purple
hearts
what did you say to somebody when they
said hey where'd you get that purple
heart from
i was on the uss liberty in 1967 when we
were attacked
and um
you know i got it for shrapnel wounds
and that was about it you know and no
one would ever pry and say you know what
the hell happened to what was going on
how how'd that occur
oh i think a couple of times you know
people would try and and pry more out of
me
and um i just wouldn't say anything i
said i just can't talk about it
um
and again it was because of the threat
of fines and imprisonment
if we ever spoke about it um being being
a
communications technician
all of my work that i did was secret so
trying to keep a secret
wasn't wasn't something that was new to
me
um
i just suppressed it to the point that
it was building up inside me
and finally i had to go to counseling
did you how do you still have your
clearance
no when i when i retired
in 2008
i relinquished my my clearance they
didn't take it away they used you
relentlessly
i just i just decided i was 62 years old
it's it's time to uh pull the plug and
uh
as you were serving in the navy
now it's 1975 now it's 1979. now it's
1982.
and you know that
you know you know you got ordered to not
say anything which look i mean there's
things that i've done which i'm not
allowed to talk about right you realize
okay i might not know everything about
the situation but i know i'm not allowed
to talk about it but i'm sure that
there's a reason for that that makes
sense
and i get it
you know was part of you thinking
you know we this is not this this
this didn't happen the way they say it
happened this seems like they're
covering it up not for any reasons of
national security but for other reasons
yes i mean i
because i work for the national security
agency
they actually did a report in 1980
that was
classified top secret
and it was their
recap of what happened to the uss
liberty
i had a copy of that report
on my desk
until i retired from the navy in
um and then i had to turn it back in
because it was you know
was that report accurate no
no
and
i mean there was information that i knew
should have been in there that had to
deal with communications
that that didn't reflect those
communications
and
the thing that they were trying to
report more than anything else
was a lack of communications that
occurred resulting from
this 100 mile
free zone i guess that israel had
declared
no
no ship should enter into that 100-mile
zone
off off the coast of cyanide
and
apparently our
naval attache
in um
in israel
had told them that we don't have any
navy ships there
sixth fleet confirmed that they didn't
have any any naval ships there and
that's
you know
a problem with us traveling by ourselves
that they um they didn't recognize that
we were over there or
they conveniently
forgot that we were there right but
there was communications that were
supposed to have been sent to us telling
us to move back off the coast and we
never received those communications and
so that's more about what this report
from nsa said and it didn't talk about
the other
intercepts that had you know the
aircraft talking to ground control are
talking about the target talking about
seeing the american flag and
you know
i don't know why that didn't come out
until later but
we kept doing
freedom of information act requests
trying to get
a lot of this documentation
back out in public so the truth could be
told